thank you fill out a March Madness prank
now I don't I catch up with it as it
goes along and I'm an old school guy I
missed 20 years ago and you actually
could have two or three years to learn
about it I can't keep up with what goes
on now but I loved watching it when it
happens but I don't like to bet on
sports I don't care enough you don't
care I love sports I have no desire to
sports gamble except for fantasy
football do you play tennis people I do
that I do I love that how obsessed are
you with fantasy football a bit yet
quite I'd like three teams just too many
and I tried to quit one you ever try to
quit a fantasy team your friends getting
take it very personally and get really
upset I couldn't get out I had a
sickness I was in a 12-step recovery
program with fantasy yeah
I it was bad I I was doing SportsCenter
one night and Keith Oberman was actually
on camera
I'm off-camera and I'm trying to
complete a trade that involved Alonzo
Mourning and Stacey Augmon
and Glen Rice and I'm doing that on the
air so I was in NBA fantasy league I'm
on the air it was bad I would go to a
draft I go I walk by a room at the
mothership and they'd have a draft and I
just go oh you guys starting I walk in
just to be in the draft
how many league how many how many leaves
were you in at once said the worst
moment okay bottom golf yeah NASCAR
baseball basketball football well and
only one in Asia are multiple I had
multiple in football multiple baseball
multiple bet on that that is that's
that's the worst I've ever heard
specific yeah I had to stop cold turkey
I'll bet you did yeah we sweat your wife
must be thrilled with all the show is
cold Brock Meyer premieres with
back-to-back episodes April 5th at 10:00
p.m. Eastern on the IFC - yeah they
assure me that's a real chat is the real
Jim yeah ok they complain how all of
this came about with the legendary
fictional broadcaster baseball
broadcaster Jim Brooklyn or gymraeg
Meyer and you are a big part of the Dan
Patrick so thank you very much one of
the rules of being Jim Brock Meyers you
can't call anybody by their first name
only
it's especially Broadcasters you are Dan
Patrick and you'll always be Dan Patrick
to me this voice fascinated me since I
was a teenager it's at you know I spoke
to Bob Costas recently he watched Brock
mine and loved it and he named it
perfectly it's the generic baseball
announcer voice it's perfectly vanilla
its especially what you heard in the 70s
and 80s I don't know why it was also the
voice that probably soldier begin soon
ayat and other things it's usually
associated with middle-of-the-road
hackish kind of announcers but Jim Brock
Meyer is a breed apart and then you took
part of me short I was thought do these
guys always sound like this including if
they're freaking out or having sex or on
drugs or whatever they're doing and
that's specifically what the series
explores so this is Funny or Die is
where it originally asked Funny or Die
now did Will Ferrell reach out to you to
put that on that side that's wills site
isn't it that is well site and I just
met well for the first time this year
after being involved for guys like eight
years no by the time I did he had just
created was up and running and there are
guys there who run that for him he's
very involved but I just you know one of
the great things about fun of your diet
you have an idea like that you go to
them and they'll produce your short it's
awesome okay but this series Jim Brock
Meyer is how old Jim brakmar is exactly
my age dan Patrick though he soon as
he's about to be 53 years old okay yeah
how racy is this it's racy
I mean it's you know like I already
warned my elderly mom mom you're not
gonna like this show I'm telling you
right now you didn't like Book of Mormon
which you did not
should I don't like this show what did
you get away with on IFC oh every what
can't you get away with that's the great
thing about you curse the nudity trio
nudity yes Meyer nude
I don't yes Jim Brian Meyer is no no
it's not frontal but you're gonna see is
you see him from behind with nothing on
doing a victory lap doing that Kirk
Gibson around the bases which come on if
you've scored with a man to peed at home
plate that's what you're going to do you
know oh wow which was what happened oh
it's about you know sex and baseball and
a lot of drinking which you know they
all go together I know if you've ever
tried to watch baseball to have sex
sober dance metrics like that it's not
like much bigger though you have to be
okay but are you taking sort of a little
bit from Harry Caray a little bit Mel
Allen like are you creating a
sportscaster broadcaster out again the
voice is just the generic one it's I
think the closest modern equivalent
would be John Miller oh but but no but
general is a terrific he's not a hack
but it's a vocal quality I say as
closest but it's more just the generic
vanilla voice and then the jackets
Lindsey Nelson I grew up in net MATLAB
yeah and it's just more that Sensibility
he's a fish out he's a guy who even
though he was he fell from grace ten
years ago in O seven his sensibilities
in 1978 you know he's an old school
baseball guy how does he keep his job
well he loses it he freaks out on the
air and then he had issues with his wife
he walked in on his wife and as he would
call it flagrante delicto with another
man had you know he's the kind of guy
that would have four or five whoever
whatever beer was sponsoring Kansas City
at the time but that day he hit the
Sazerac ride pretty hard too and after a
bottle of it was in a blackout drunk
flips out on the air talking about his
wife using a strap-on and whatnot and
which is a belt that mommy is where to
penetrate daddies as a point sound can
we say that this is my ID neuter down
there's nothing wrong with the word
penetrate come on
anyway so lose his job spent ten years
out of baseball and the series picks up
with him trying to get back into
starting at the very bottom rung the
minor minor league baseball
he's Hank Azaria does a lot of voices
not just brought Meyer which appears
April 5th at 10:00 p.m. Eastern on IFC
many voices with the Simpsons and run
down the voices here oh there's too many
to name
how many Oh Jim Brock may occasionally
appear
as a Simpsons voice we just don't call
them Jim brakmar but my big guys are Moe
the bartender chief Wiggum op who the
kwik-e-mart attendant comic book a
lettuce will do the messy NIEM them way
that comic book guy
mollari mentioned a poor of course is a
wonderful man a police chief Wiggum
there's Cletus he's a slack-jawed yoku
professor frank of clash dan was a
wonderful man I'm quite a brilliant man
um Carl I misread Coyle you know here
lots of him lose a cop another favorite
of mine a cat about screw favourite
Ljubica I want to talk about the process
here of the voice when you get a voice
get a character how do they marry the
two on The Simpsons there so this call
of T's is what this is they will just
hand us a script wait wait wait this is
a T or is it cheese I understand we're
gonna break that out like still come
then let me think about it for like two
to four minutes when I get back like
like Keith Morrison on Dateline when he
gives you a tea oh and by the way Fritzi
will do is Marge Simpson impersonation
for you now that's a teeth yeah now and
I want an honest grade on on it okay I'd
you guys could he fill in if like nine
people got sick could he fill in his
card symptom all of that all of that
coming up right after the break here on
the damp and exciting
actor producer writer director comedian
oh come on
all those flashes there that well they
were true at least at one time yes you
got one more slash than Cranston does he
doesn't have comedian on his and and
could and should although I wasn't a
night Ekta CLE was a stand-up for about
a year early in my career so how tough
is being a stand-up comedian brutal
absolutely brutal really really hard did
you need to drink before you went on or
need to drink when you got off I both
you know before during and after I
lucked I was very young and I stumbled
on stage at the Comedy Store in LA and
didn't even realize it was an audition
situation and got hired who was whose
performance
back then you just the days like Pauly
Shore and Andrew Dice Clay and Sam
Kinison was still dominating then and a
lot of guys you know came up through
there and calmly sure was a particularly
brutal place I never got through my act
I only got heckled that's true and I had
no game I had no response I was young I
didn't know anything and some older
comedians took pity on me and said dude
you can't just let the audience destroy
you you have to say some things back to
them and they gave me a few like stock
in some back yeah which I would use so
uh thank you you got one sure like you'd
say sir please this is my job I don't
interrupt you at your job when you're on
your knees the men's okay that's I
thought we might be going right well
Hank Azaria has a new show called
do a cockapoo I know I know and as soon
as it left my mouth I said no premieres
with back-to-back episodes April 5th at
10:00 p.m. Eastern on the independent
film ship I am sick I see yeah
most of this appearance is not going to
be able to be shown it's not sad like
well it's nice to see you anyway um is
there maybe we should have Jim Brock
Meyer on at some point and and he's
that's part of the show so we can have
me you would be on for me to interview
you
I mean that's part of the Sirian just
yeah oh yeah I know yeah well you're a
very difficult man to book we tried to
get you yeah I know
well I'll oh I know I mean very very
difficult we caught you eight years ago
when you did the short watching a little
career-low all right explain the process
with the Simpsons here if you come up
with a voice or do they come up with a
character and then they need a voice how
does that work it is always the latter
they write the script and then they cast
it you know Harry Shearer damn castle
net and I do most of the male voices on
the show and they just divide it up well
each week we do like five or ten and in
the early days there were many new
characters each week and you had to sit
there and think about what voice would
go with this character and then that
over the years you know you accrue more
and more characters and it's easier then
it also gets
easier just to kind of figure out how
things should sound okay they come up
with a character right you do you see
the character do you have a picture of
the character no they describe the
character yeah like you know I can
remember for example professor Frank
let's take professor Frank okay they
didn't have any specific voice in mind
but they cast me as it before they heard
me do it and I was like you know did
Jerry Louis I believe did the original
naughty professor I would be certainly a
frivolous and entertaining way to go
here and I tossed it out there and did
it that way and they laughed and if they
laugh you know in comedy that means it's
going to work so and then you know dr.
Nick Riviera I'm like well I do a very
bad Ricky Ricardo impression or at least
what I remember Ricky Ricardo something
like so that's the last and yeah you
know laughter ensued and then that was
it did you know a bartender who sounded
like mo mo is the first character ever
did and that I auditioned for the show
with that voice and no actually I was
doing a play at the time in LA or as
playing a drug deal or a lowlife guy and
I was doing a pretty bad Al Pacino from
Dog Day Afternoon impression and oh no I
don't sounds like this Al Pacino
looked like this now but back in the day
he was up high he lost more like this
right Michael Corleone is talked like
this so I did that and they said we like
that voice but we needed to be a
gravelly voice so if you take young Al
Pacino and you'll make him gravity that
equals motor bartender does Pacino know
that you're sort of paying tribute to
him I don't know I have not never I
haven't heard from Al I wanted to acted
with him in heat we did a scene together
and we both have the same birthday
interestingly enough and we did that
scene on our birthday but in that in
that scene in now De Niro and Pacino
never appeared together they did and he
they had a scene together actually a
tape man only knees they shot the seated
okay at a restaurant and they had this
great conversation okay I thought that
that that was the big thing that they
weren't on the set at the same time for
the most part that was true I think only
in
one scene where they have really
together do you crank up you know prank
phone calls I used to as in my youth
quite a lot with these voices yes yes
but what would you like who are you
pranking I did one they went growing up
in Forest Hills I was in the 14th floor
I could see out my window is I remember
the old days of phone booth hey kiddo
you kids at home
it used to be things called phone booth
and you'd put money in them and you'd
have to actually call people and there
was one I could see out my window and I
got the number of it and I would call it
and when people were walking by it and I
would use the Brock Meyer voice I'd say
like a you know hi this is a madman
madman douzo from WPA L hey there's one
thousand dollars hidden in the red
Nissan Sentra right next to and you've
got 60 seconds to find it and I watched
people attempt terrific for the car and
it was right near a police station - and
my goal was always to actually get
somebody arrested um pretty does Marge
Simpson and I now do people audition
when you meet people do you have people
who say hey listen to my impersonation
or you know listen my voice with Ned
Flanders or what do you think of this
occasionally and they usually regret it
they go you know hey I do a pretty good
job alright let's hear it and then they
get a little panic to let go I maybe
shouldn't said that not do it
I but yes occasionally I want you to be
honest with fritzy's Marge Simpson
impersonation this is emergency
situation that somebody couldn't do
Marge Simpson hi fritzy let me close my
eyes all right here we go Oh homie so
exciting Hank Azaria's in the New York
City man cave I'm a Dan Patrick show
right now he's old Bluffs and handsome
did you know he has a new show called
Brock Meyer premiering April 5th with
back-to-back episodes at 10:00 Eastern
on IFC heesu cat's meow and then the
sisters might say okay did you think I'm
actually going to watch that I first of
all that was unbelievably scripted I
mean you're really you really prepared I
said I wanted to make a good impression
I'll just roll her on a break it's like
you're auditioning like for Yale Drama
School
that's the first is that a compliment
well I appreciate the appreciat the plot
without the plug what did you think
well here's the problem well if you if
you if you don't if it's not set up is
just off the cuff
then it gets judged as if it's like a
scripted piece of material that we
really want professional quality from
that wasn't bad you want my honest
accession assessment yeah especially for
a man doing it that was who's you know
not of nada not an animation professor
what professional I give you few plus
for that okay my playback right I think
I know yes it was past
let's for this way if we needed like
somebody just to tempt the voice and for
Julie then would come in later in
perfectly except we would not throw
anybody else off excellent in the room
but I will take for military I will then
I you know I didn't mean to be you know
on Greta that I appreciate how much work
you put in with this but Hank Hanks
involved in the craft I understand he's
he's an actor for it and you know yc+
what are you trying to say I understand
I'll take that that's still a passing
grade in that circle it's a long way
Mike I mean you know that was a very
nice way of saying keep your day job I
well I I wanted to bring this up you
were in a movie Along Came Polly yes
okay I thought there were
performance-enhancing drugs involved in
your character because you were in out
you know and you are ripped like a bard
you've got a setback you're Jack there
yeah is that all-natural 100% natural
but you're not the first person to ask
me that question one got one it randomly
in LA somebody I would say I know I was
some restaurant for lunch Keiko screen
says ask me that question says you know
were you did you take steroids for a
long can't when you did all camp I and I
said no I did anyone yes you did
I'm like it looks like alright well then
why am i yeah bigger arms back then too
I guess like where do they go
what tune I'm 53 I was in the gym three
times a day
let you know a few times in my career I
got in roles where you're basically
going to be gnashing was naked in that
movie and it frightened you into the gym
and what else you do as an actor leading
up to a movie
I had a job that I'd actually go show up
at what about a nude scene there yeah I
mean yeah how was that how does it work
draw me like doing a love scene yeah
sexy yeah it's very highly highly and
who are you with in that movie I was
with Debra Messing
yeah we like to ever mix a lot yeah my
buddy Ernie who I'm about to see for
lunch I grew up with in far so yeah he
gets infuriated on the days when that's
my job when it's my job to pretend to
have sex with Debra Messing or Kelly
Lynch or Amanda Peet who ever been
fortunate enough to do that with we like
Kelly Lynch to look at Rodell she's a
lovely woman do you realize you know
that story right house is one of my
favorite movie of all time you pain
don't hurt you built Bill Murray
sir Wes Lamar sorry Bill Murray and his
brothers call Kelly Lynch's husband
every etches Mitch every time the scene
is on where she's having sex they will
built with Swayze milk all calculations
husband to say your wife's having sex
with this has been going on personally I
love that story it's been going on for
20 years that's bent because I love Road
House oh my favorite story connected to
having sex in a movie this is attributed
to be the Tom Hanks but I I think some
older actor said it for him before love
scenes like that he will turn to the
actress and say I apologize if I do
apologize as I jump and that pretty much
copy other does yes of its Brock Meyer
premieres April 5th back-to-back
episodes at 10:00 p.m. Eastern on IFC
he's Hank Azaria actor producer writer
director comedian and also I'm a
longshoreman Patrick I like that energy
flash in there as well of Congrats on
getting Brock Meyer thank you and truly
thank you for doing the short years ago
it made a big difference it helped a lot
I remember you weren't sure if you were
going to do this as a TV series and I
said why wouldn't you if if you feel
like you can you know wrap enough
characters and
storylines there and it was an
interesting character that we've never
seen no I woulda loved you just you
never nothing ever gets made you never
get to really do anything it's it's
amazing we got to do this so so april
5th on AMC it's called brock meyer
jama'at Meyer and thank you for stopping
by Hank hey thanks for having me
the Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience